federal prosecutors have charged nearly
50 people in a College Admission scandal
that involves wealthy parents and
celebrities bribing testing companies
and colleges to get their kids into
elite universities including Stanford
Georgetown and of course dear old Yale
we will explain why the big college bust
was inevitable then Media Matters takes
another shot at Tucker Carlson the
Greenpeace co-founder says that the
green New Deal would end civilization
and Nancy Pelosi finally comes out
against impeachment
I'm Michael Knowlton this is the Michael
Nolt real
[Music]
this is basically breaking news it's
within about the last hour that this has
come out the biggest scandal ever to
face merican higher education
it was so predictable we knew it was
going to happen there are a lot of
victims here they're basically only
victims here we will explain in great
detail the path forward how to avoid
things like this in the future but first
let's make a little money honey with zip
recruiter hiring is challenging
especially now if you don't know if the
kids really should have gotten into
college or not so there is one place
that you can go where hiring is simple
where you can grow your business you can
connect to qualified candidates that
places zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
Keo wles zip recruiter sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
they don't just stop there that with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job as
the applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match it was so effective 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate on the site within
the first day this is the way to do it
now don't just throw a spaghetti at the
wall don't just hope that the perfect
candidate wanders in the door and says
hello there that's not going to happen
what you need to do is allow this
technology from zip recruiter to find
the candidates go out there find them
for you bring them to your attention
right now my listeners can try zip order
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles KO wles
that is zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
KO wles
zip zip recruiter comm slash KN o WL e s
zipper the smartest way to hire
now today these days if you want to get
a job everyone tells you you need a
college degree everyone needs to go to
college everyone needs to go to a
four-year college everyone needs to go
to the same colleges that's what we have
been told and this lie has led to the
largest scandal ever in American higher
education this scandal is huge it
includes business leaders it includes
you know captains of industry whatever
this is this is a really big deal this
includes Lori Loughlin Lori Loughlin was
on full house this includes Felicity
Huffman Felicity Huffman was on
Desperate Housewives parents apparently
paid consultants twenty five million
dollars from 2011 through this year to
cheat the system and get their kids into
these schools so what is going on why
when I saw this I you know I don't watch
Desperate Housewives I don't you know
tuna every night but I've heard the name
of Felicity Huffman I thought why on
earth would a well-known celebrity
actress get involved in such a sordid
crime such as this and the reason is
obvious because these college degrees
really really matter in our society
these college degrees especially at
elite universities carry a ton of weight
in the society they're incredibly
valuable and so parents who want to give
their kids a leg up will do anything
they can to get their kids in there but
at the same time there's a flip side to
this which is that people got away with
cheating their way into these schools
they got away with it for years and now
what are we on the eighth year of this
because it's a lot harder to get in than
it is to stay in I know this just from a
personal experience I you know I wasn't
on college all that long ago and it is
very hard to get into Yale it was very
hard you need basically perfect SATs
valedictorian top of the you know
whatever you need to have check every
box class president all these things
it's very very hard parents put their
kids through all these study courses SAT
prep courses they do a zillion
extracurriculars I did is I did
these things and even then it's very
hard to get it once you get in however
it's a lot easier to stay in so you can
be I mean these days it yeah it's still
hard I guess to get an A but to get an
a-minus or a B+ is pretty easy it's
actually probably hard to get a C I know
I never got anything below a B I don't
think I don't I don't think I'd
certainly never got to see in my entire
time in college and it's not because I
was paying attention in class all the
time when I was in college I was doing a
zillion extracurricular activities I was
off campus a lot doing politics and
still it's very hard because there is
great inflation they protect you once
you're in they want to make sure they
have a high graduation rate so these
kids who didn't even get the is a
t-score they just cheated their way and
they were able to stay in them it means
that higher education has become an
empty husk of what it once was there
it's largely a facade so it so there are
a lot of questions that are raised first
of all is it just these kids I don't
think it's just these kids who cheated
that's that's not the only knock against
the meritocratic college system we have
what about athletes one way actually
that these kids were cheating to get in
is that the parents would pay these
consultants to bribe coaches at all of
these elite universities the coaches
would pretend that they were recruiting
the kids for athletics
they'd pocket the money where they'd
give the money to the school's athletic
program then the kids would get to the
school and then all of a sudden they
would drop out of the sport because at
these elite universities you don't
actually have to play the sport once
you're there
I remember this for me I had a good
friend at Yale he was recruiter for
football he comes over to Yale and he
decides he wants to become a serious
scholar he wants to really devote all of
his time to classics and to thinking I
guess it's sort of the opposite of this
scam it's the opposite of these kids he
actually wanted to become much more
academically rigorous so I think his
freshman year he quit the football team
doesn't matter because of these elite
schools your scholarship your financial
aid or whatever is not tied to athletics
so you can you get in for football or
whatever they lower the academic
standards for you and then you quit
football immediately so okay that's one
aspect
but let's not also forget that very
often the the super-rich not just the
very rich not just the these parents not
just the Felicity Huffman rich but this
SuperDuper rich to captains of industry
they just buy their kids way into the
schools by building a dormitory or
building a lecture hall or something and
so once once they do that they give a
hundred million dollars or something
fifty million dollar donation how come
that's not cheating but this is cheating
well in part it's because at least the
rich people are honest about it they're
saying here's my check here's my money
you can all see that I donated to it my
name is on the front of the building
there and my kid happens to go here you
do the math one thing that these parents
were doing was cheating they were
pretending that their kids passed all of
the academic rigor they were pretending
that the kids merited their place at the
University now I've heard that at a lot
of elite schools it's basically 50/50
50% athletes and legacies people whose
parents went to the school and then 50
percent got in on their own academic
merit and I got to tell you something
this is one aspect of college that I
really liked it's something that I think
is losing cachet in America but it's
very important which is that because I I
didn't come from a super wealthy family
I didn't know the Felicity Huffman could
have bought my way into college
so I legitimately had the privilege of
considering myself in the people in
college who merited getting in
academically studied for the tests got
good grades on the tests got good grades
in school I got to be there that gives
you a feeling of self-worth that gives
you a feeling of confidence that gives
you a feeling of belonging of not being
lesser than and for these kids who got
in because mommy cheated they don't have
that feeling I mean even people who do
it the old-fashioned way where daddy
buys a building or something they don't
have that feeling as much when I got
into college I had a family friend say
to me Michael you ought to be really
proud and I said oh you know people get
into good colleges all the time and he
said right but for my kids I wrote
check and and your parents didn't write
a check so you know that actually that
does make you feel good when you earn
something it feels a lot better than
when something is just handed to you and
this is true not just of the admissions
but of the whole College process now
this is the whole thing I mean you just
see the tail wagging the dog in every
way why are the college's prioritizing
athletics over scholarship why are they
prioritizing pulling in money over
pulling in the best students and
scholars why are the parents so
desperate to get their kids into these
schools this is I think a problem of an
overly democratic culture because in
this culture in democracies we hate when
people have different things different
privileges Democratic cultures
egalitarian cultures Alexis de
Tocqueville recognized this in democracy
in America they tend to level and so all
of a sudden if somebody has something
everybody else needs to have something
everybody else needs to have that
privilege so now we are told that
everybody has to go to college so that
only the most elite degrees seem to
count for anything
you know when I was in college I studied
with probably the greatest living
historian Donald Kagan Donald Donald
Kagan went to Brooklyn College that's
where he graduated from now these days
there's such a difference there's such a
fear of feeling that if you go to
Brooklyn College you could never end up
at a very elite university but in those
days that wasn't true because Brooklyn
College was a very very rigorous college
when Donald Kagan went to that College
there wasn't a sense that every single
person in the country had to go to
college so if you went to college you
wanted to be there you wanted to learn
something you were motivated you were
paying for it yourself very likely or GI
Bill was paying for it you already paid
your dues in the service there was you
had some skin in the game you had some
real stakes into it now that isn't the
case so now everyone is going to college
college is considered a good thing it's
good for everyone
college is a good thing for
some people it's not a good thing for
every a four-year college degree is not
only not a good thing for some people it
is a bad thing for some people if you
want to study the liberal arts if you
want to study history or English or
philosophy or something you wanna have a
general education then you want to
specialize and then you want to
generalize again at the top a sort of it
looks like the letter I that's the kind
of traditional career when you go to get
a liberal education if you want to do
that if you were suited to do that if
that is your path then you should go to
college it is a positive good to go to
college if that is not your path if you
want to be a very very narrow specialist
let's say you want to be anything from a
plumber or an electrician to an engineer
let's say that's what you you don't need
to go get a four-year liberal arts
college degree why would you need to do
that let's say you want to be an actor
or an actress you don't need to get it
four-year college degree let's say you
want to be a musician let's say you want
to be I don't know you want to be an
athlete you want to you don't need to
get a four-year college degree if you
want to work in the service industry
depends on what the job is but you don't
need a four-year college degree so many
if you want to be a computer programmer
you don't need a four-year college
degree all the biggest billionaire
famous computer geniuses of our era
dropped out of college you don't need
that it for certain jobs it helps for
certain jobs you don't need it in in
fact the liberal arts very specifically
are not designed to get you a job
they're designed for what you do in your
free time how you make sense of your
freedom what you how you make sense of
your leisure how we earn our freedom in
a free society but that is not what
ideologue s'what leveling' leftist
ideologue tell us they tell us everybody
has to go to college so now of course
parents are gonna pay a lot of money to
cheat their way to get their kids into
college in this society if that college
credential is so important they're gonna
do everything that they can of course
and this raises another question what do
we do about the kids who got in so let's
say Felicity Huffman x' kid you know
gets into college say
someone else's kids still there what if
the kid is getting a 4.0 GPA actually
some colleges now don't even have GPAs
Brown University doesn't have a GPA so
you can't even tell what the grades are
so they're doing fine you're doing it
just as well if not better than other
kids who got a 1600 on the SAT or
whatever
well should we kick them out is that the
right thing to do no the problem goes a
lot deeper the problem is the university
itself
when you think about who the victims are
here a lot of people are going to say
the kids who didn't get in because mommy
cheated okay yeah
yeah those kids are victims that would
have been awful I mean I remember the
stress of college admissions season it's
a really tough kids because there's a
lot of value put on it and our society
kids put a lot of pressure on themselves
so the kids have worked very hard who
didn't get in they're victims the
universities are victims the
universities which have been watered
down and democratized and hollowed out
and destroyed they're victims of this
scandal and the kids of these very rich
people are victims because they have no
sense of accomplishment and their
parents are crooks
imagine that you're growing up you know
you're at a formative age 16 17 and your
parent tells you you know Johnny you're
just not smart enough you're not smart
enough and good enough to merit getting
into an elite University so what we're
gonna do is cheat and rob another kid of
that educational opportunity so that you
can get in even though you don't deserve
it can you imagine being that kid that's
what you hear you think well on the
downside my parents think that I'm a
failure but on the bright side at least
they're criminals at least my parents
are criminals this is there are no
winners there is no winner here nobody
nobody wins so what is the solution this
the first solution is you've got to push
up against the worst instincts of
democratic and egalitarian culture
you've got to push back against it what
democratic and egalitarian culture wants
to do
is make everybody exactly the same put
everyone on exactly the same path waste
everybody's time what you need to do is
allow for variety in diversity
it's Chiron I sound like I'm talking
like a leftist I'm using the words that
leftist use the difference is that I
actually mean it you need to permit
variety and diversity if somebody early
on has an aptitude for I don't know
engineering or something coding learn to
code I'm probably gonna get kicked off
of Twitter for saying that if somebody
has an aptitude for that put him on a
track for that trip this is it's called
tracking the Europe has tracking the
United States had this for a long time
but our overly democratic nature will
not permit it we want everyone to have
every opportunity forever you never need
to choose anything you never need to
pick a path you know no no no just
generalized generalized generalize but
event you that only works to a degree
eventually you need to take all of that
potential and turn it into some
actuality and it wastes so much time
just to constantly be all potential
constantly be generalizing put people on
tracks if you know if a kid is just not
cut out for the classroom just doesn't
like school doesn't like reading books
isn't gonna start liking to read books
he wants to work in a trade let's say he
wants to become a like an electrician or
something put him on that track before
he's 22 years old and $200,000 in debt
what good does that do anybody because
if you get into these schools and you
really can't do anything further ball
maybe you can't do anything at the
University maybe some schools don't have
too much grade inflation you flunk out
that just puts you in debt and you're
even more of a failure or let's say you
graduate you've got all of this debt now
and you have no skill and you have no
interest and you have no path what good
that hasn't done anybody any good it
just mismatches you for your future so
maybe put that kid on a path to a trade
maybe someone wants to join the military
right out of high school they don't need
to go to a four-year college right away
maybe if they want to be an officer or a
career guy then they can do that or
maybe they want to enlist do that allow
for variety
and diversity stop homogenizing
everything people are different this is
a beautiful aspect of life I get a great
thrill out of different people telling
me different opinions having different
experiences
the next thing you've got to do is
reduce the federal college subsidies
I'm not saying cut them all off I don't
think there should be totally radical
drastic change immediately I think that
disadvantages kids who have been waiting
their turn in this college cycle and to
cut off their opportunities radically
try to change the culture is
fundamentally anti conservative and it's
not going to work what you need to do is
steadily decrease federal subsidies for
colleges these federal government
subsidies have created very perverse
incentives
they've given colleges the ability to
raise a lot of administrative bloat they
have given colleges when you guarantee
the fed of the student loans they've
given colleges a free check to increase
tuition which saddles kids with hundreds
of thousands of dollars of debt this has
created terrible incentives and it's
made the universities reliant on the
government it's made them more
politically correct it's made them more
willing to politically censor people
very bad idea
Jen glue is slowly gradually you've got
to reduce those subsidies and speaking
of the administrative bloat fire them
all fire every single one of them the
deputy assistant deputy Dean of
inclusion and diversity and nothing
needs to be fired yesterday end it that
is awful they do nothing all they do is
sit in their office and try to justify
their ridiculous and useless job and
stir up trouble on campus and destroy
liberal education fire them immediately
next reduce the role of sports in
colleges reduce the it's just too
dominant it creates too much opportunity
for corruption and too much opportunity
to corrupt scholarship and the purpose
of the university next eliminate fake
academic disciplines we joke about
lesbian dance theory there are really
ridiculous disciplines out there women
the sexuality and Gender Studies
ethnicity race and migration studies
virtually any department that ends in
studies with I suppose the exception of
the language departments because some
those engine studies but other than
ancient or modern languages when it were
just talking about cultural studies dead
that's not an academic discipline that
is not serious scholarship that is just
ideology those have to go away because
those departments attract professors and
students who are not fit to be at a
university
they are generally less intelligent and
less educated and they make up words and
they don't mean anything and they damage
the credibility of the University you
have to get rid of those and finally
what would the other way to fix this is
for employers to stop putting so much
credibility lending so much credibility
to a meaningless certificate if you get
into a good college what does that mean
until this scandal it meant that you
were pretty intelligent you had a pretty
high raw intelligence you're a pretty
good IQ maybe you did well in high
school you did very well on a
standardized test that matters it
matters if if your employee is
intelligent but it it's not all that
matters
education matters to what you can do
skills matter to there's a kind of funny
thing we joke about this on backstage at
the Daily wire where you know Ben went
to Harvard Law drue went to Berkeley I
went to Yale so the people with the
their shows went to these very elite
colleges and our bosses didn't go to
college
none of them went to college and so
really it tells you something about the
value of an education if if what you
want to do if what really gets you going
is talking about Edmund Burke all day
long yes it does for me then yes you
probably need to go to college if you
want to run a gigantic business if you
want to be an entrepreneur if you want
to start a gigantic business anything
from us to Facebook to Microsoft or
whatever I don't see any evidence that
you need a college degree I don't see
any evidence that you need to graduate I
don't know that you need to go in the
first place different tracks it's ok and
employers really good employers know
this you look at the resume ok then
throw it out see what the person can do
see what the person is like to talk to
see what their hard skills are this will
be the only way if you Institute even
2/3
of those suggestions you will go a long
way to stopping this this big college
scam not just the particular scam of
cheating to get in but the big scam
overall which is that our education has
been watered down a joke with my friend
that he and I are just complete dunces
and I'm only half joking because if we
had had our education 60 years ago we
would have had to learn Latin ancient
Greek maybe Hebrew these days if you
graduate from Yale with honors with
summa [ __ ] laude a degree in English you
can do all of that without ever reading
Shakespeare that is a scandal that's the
big College scam and it's very important
a free society cannot remain free very
long if it doesn't take education
seriously this is where I differ from my
more rock-ribbed maybe you know kind of
populist conservative friends who say
who cares burn all of education to the
ground no no free society will dissolve
in two seconds
once education is truly eliminated once
liberal education is eliminated so it
really matters that you can save this
you have to go out and try to bring it
back and you know one one way that we
try to do this in a in a popular way
just as part of the show is we go around
and do all of these college speeches and
so right now I'm actually with Dan at
Michigan and Michigan is giving a speech
tonight at University of Michigan and
just it's as though you know all
naturist but aren't unknown to thee the
universities make our point before we
can even say it which is that he's
getting protests they didn't want him to
come and now the history department is
holding a rival event to been speech
called when provocateurs dabble in
history ben shapiro and the
Enlightenment the Enlightenment therasp
history but this is supposed to there
were the serious guys
we're the serious academic history
department Ben he's just dabbling he's
just a provocateur and yet the
SuperDuper serious history department
uses a ridiculous ideological made-up
word called enlightenment listen to this
is what they say they say they sent out
a letter they said
hi historians join the history club in
the history department tomorrow for an
important and exciting event in response
to been Shapiro's visit to campus when
provocateurs to dabble in history ben
shapiro and the enlightenment will
feature speakers and panelists
responding to Shapiro's attacks on
campuses in academia along with his new
history book the right side of history
ben Shapiro's attacking campuses he had
been Shapiro's attacking a khadeem
you're attacking academia with stupid
made-up terms like that and trying to
get speakers banned from campus you're
the ones doing it you're the ones
hollowing out higher education you don't
even know here's just a little evidence
they say we're honored to be joined by
dean angela Dillard professor Ann Berg
professor John Carson and professor
Hussein fancy all these see they brought
professors not Ben Ben's just a
provocateur who dabbles in history
they're bringing the real professor so I
said ok I bet that these professors are
a total joke I just it was a hunch I had
call it a good bed I got pretty good
bedding instincts so I googled them
guess what turns out I was right for at
least half of them Angela Dillard she's
a Dean already makes me a little suspect
ever she has a BA in justice morality
constitutional democracy so fake degree
fake undergraduate degree she has a
master's degree in American culture so
fake master's degree and a PhD in also
American culture so she has three or
four degrees in nothing in fake
everything that is that is nothing I I
don't know do I have a degree in
American culture I go to the movies once
a week is that a merit is that a degree
and Berg that's the other super
historian here first of all not a
professor she's a lecturer here she is
from Michigan I guess when they got a
PhD at Michigan she studies film and
public leisure in Nazi Germany as well
as the politics and this is a direct
quote the politics of waste and
recycling in the Third Reich if if I
were going to if I were writing the
producers or something if I were writing
parody of academia what I would do I
would have the the professor specialize
in the politics of waste and recycling
in the Third Reich how frivolous a
couple a couple of the other professors
are apparently more legitimate but at
least half the panel total frauds ben
shapiro is much more of an historian
than those two people but this is what
they do its though they have the PhD
they call themselves professor even
though they're not really professors
they see what's there they have an
academic pedigree oh it's a facade it's
fake
we have fake news now we have fake
scholarship fake academia and they have
to have a counter event at a universe at
a university a real university typically
you would go and hear somebody speak
someone wants to give a lecture you
agree you disagree you don't know if you
agree you go and hear them speak and
then maybe later you give a response so
what you're doing a university brings
everybody together then you share ideas
and then you come up with other ideas
but here in American universities today
instead of going to the event you try to
get the event shut down you try to get
the person censored you try to get him
kicked off campus and then when that
doesn't work you go to the deputy Dean
of inclusion or whatever and then you
you I don't know you hold a counter or
protest event and then you and you just
go to your separate events and that's it
no one talks to anybody it's not a
university and if they're not gonna
behave like universities don't treat
them as such if you're an employer give
less credit to it if you're the federal
government stop funding it and if your
parents and children have the courage to
make what are really the better academic
choices for your kids regardless of what
that is we have a lot more to get to
Media Matters taking another shot at
Tucker
we've got Nancy Pelosi coming out
against impeachment and then Greenpeace
telling us that the Greenpeace
co-founder telling us that the green new
deal will end civilization all of that
in just a second but first you have to
go to Daley wire calm Daley wire.com ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership
you get what don't you get you get me
get the Andrew Klavan sure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get them out wall
show you get test questions in the
mailbag that's coming up Thursday you
get to ask questions
backstage that's coming up tomorrow by
the way tomorrow tune in to our next
episode of daily wire backstage march
madness Edition daily wire God King
Jeremy boring Ben Shapiro Andrew Klavan
Alicia crass and myself will be smoking
stogies drinking whiskey and laughing
laughing at this wild crazy political
culture of ours as always only daily
water subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today go to daily wire comm get the
leftist here's tumblr lest you have to
drink out of these sad little cups like
I'm drinking out of now on the road
Taylor why did I come over right back
Media Matters is going after Tucker
Carlson again by the way this really
drives me this is a really side point
this is a really minor point but I have
to make it Media Matters is such a
stupid organization that they don't even
know that the word media is plural media
is the plural of medium so you have a
medium you have this medium the
newspapers or the television or the
radio or this media multiple mediums
equals media so really the organization
should be called media matter for
America not media matters but I'm not
surprised that an organization like this
doesn't know how to use the English
language a side point now they're going
after Tucker again we talked about what
they were doing yesterday so they're
going after him again they have a
headline quote unearthed audio shows
Tucker Carlson using white nationalist
rhetoric and making racist remarks okay
first of all these guys are are so
overusing the phrase white nationalists
that that word like racist is basically
now deprived of meaning it used to have
a meaning it did racist use to have a
meaning now they don't they don't have
because they use them against Tucker
Carlson and so there's no credibility
but Media Matters did a good job here in
the sense that they got the one-two
punch they released a few audio clips
yesterday and Tucker comes that defends
himself some okay that one didn't quite
take him off the air so then they hit
him again today with these new clips if
you haven't heard them yet here or
though here's the white nationalists
basically Adolf Hitler himself reciting
mind Kampf on fox news Tucker Carlson is
a crappy place filled with a bunch of
you know semi-literate
monkeys I just have zero sympathy for
them or their culture a culture where
people just don't use toilet paper or
Forks women you know I agree with you
their culture is but you're in there
when no white men you know they've
contributed some I would say like
creating civilization the stuff I think
they've done a pretty whatever Obama
would kick here playing basketball yeah
oh he's black Santa he's a real brother
hey do you back he is how is he black
for one thing he's one white parent one
black really so that makes him well why
is any white there's some really good I
mean immigrants I just think it's you
know people who come to this country or
I have something to offer be hot be
really smart you know what I mean
especially that last one people who come
to this country ought to have something
to offer so look he's on a shock jock
show it's the same show like the Bubba
Gump love show or so I don't remember
the name of it and he's speaking in a
joking manner obviously I don't think
that if Tucker Carlson were the
President of the United States he would
say in his immigration policy they have
to be hot or really smart you know I
don't think he would say that but that's
a good joke and a fair point that he
makes which is if you come to this
country you should have something to
offer and if you don't have something to
offer this country you shouldn't come
into this country duh that's the
immigration policy of every other
country on earth as well we happen to
have the most generous one but that
makes sense
and so what Tucker says be hot or be
really smart okay what else you know
some of the points he's making here
which he makes in an offensive way
nobody says he's not making them in an
offensive way
in fact he's intentionally making them
in an offensive way because he's on a
shock jock show shock jock it's not feel
really Pleasant jock it's a shock dress
was to shock you so he I'm sure he would
say that do yes these these were very
offensive but some of the points that
he's making most people would agree with
he jokes about all of the Animus in the
popular culture against white man he
said I think white men have done
something I mean you know there are not
so bad they like you know created
civilization what we call civilization
Western civilization or I guess what we
call civilization broadly the thing that
we know is civilization the thing that
we live in is civilization the
civilization that is spread throughout
the whole world that we have spread from
c-2
see and far beyond it is European it
comes from Europe comes from Rome
it comes from London it comes from
Greece guess it comes from Jerusalem as
well it comes from the Jews as well I
don't know the Jews white or not I know
this is a big debate among the left I
guess but that is your that the point
he's making that civilization has come
from Europe is true but he says but how
was Barack Obama black he's also white
it's also a fair point
why is Barack Obama his mother's white
he was raised largely by a white family
if not exclusively why is he not
considered white well the left might say
because of because the very fact that he
had black skin means that he did not
have the privileges that white people
have even though he's half white because
he had black skinny doesn't have those
privileges why don't know he went to a
very good school in Hawaii then he went
to Columbia and Ivy League school then
he went to Harvard Law School Ivy League
school then he became a state senator
very quickly then he became a u.s.
senator at like age five and then he
wrote two memoirs about himself that
both got published and then he became
the president he's like the most
privileged guy ever what are you talking
about so that the point the Tucker is
making they're also fair enough point
then he says the things about the Iraqis
he called that's not nice fair it not
nice nobody would want to do that nobody
should ever suggest that human beings
are not human beings
don't you agree congresswoman Alon Omar
that is silly to even think is it true
that you just think that he's more
polished in from awkward and by the way
Tucker Carlson was making jokes in a
shock jock show Alana Omar is speaking
seriously in the halls of Congress both
saying that human beings aren't humans
well it's a lot worse when Allah no more
does it isn't it it's exactly the same
thing with exactly the same words
yikes that's not good almost exactly the
same words the same point uh so awkward
yeah of course you shouldn't do that
what I guess you might say what Tucker
Carlson was saying was an offensive joke
would you say that I guess you could but
he's saying offensive things no you
can't defend offensive things you can
you can you don't defend the points I
guess but you defend saying offensive
things because of context if you're on a
shock jock show you're gonna talk like
that now you might say well he shouldn't
have gone on that show okay fine you can
give Tucker Carlson career advice
I guess fair enough here's an example
though here's the example of what
context really matters I try my best not
to use curse words on this show I'd I
think I don't think I have before maybe
I have once or twice but I certainly
intend not to now if I'm at the bar at
midnight with the boys smoking a cigar I
will use curse words it doesn't make me
a hypocrite because I don't use curse
words on this show if I say them at the
bar because context matters context
matters a lot it's inappropriate to say
these sort of things in a polite
civilized forum it is much more
appropriate to say these things if
you're telling a joke with the boys or
if you're talking to a shock jock now
the real question because we've done
that we've bought into the media matters
hands we've done what they want us to do
why are we talking about Tucker Carlson
why are we talking about him at all you
know they use the phrase audio was on
earthed it didn't just dig itself up
from the ground it's not like a potato
you know growing up no uh it didn't it
didn't do that Media Matters paid
somebody a lot of money to find anything
that they could find to try to take down
Tucker Carlson why because Media Matters
believes that Tucker Carlson's voice and
his show is a threat to the left's
agenda that's why if Tucker Carlson
weren't a threat Media Matters wouldn't
have spent a lot of money to pay
somebody to dig up dirt on Tucker
Carlson to try to shut him up and then
what did they find they found that he
talked to a shock jock once what are
they gonna find on me they're gonna find
I talked to a guy in a bar and I used
some naughty language that's the word
Tucker he said I used naughty language
with a shock jock yeah that's the
appropriate word to describe it
what are they gonna find they're gonna
say oh my gosh so-and-so made a joke 15
years ago off with his head they're not
doing it because they're offended by the
jokes they're doing it because they want
to silence his serious work what does
this matter
what does it matter Tucker Carlson is a
media figure he is not a politician he's
not serving in Congress even if Tucker
Carlson made those jokes today on his
Fox show he is still a media figure he
is still not a legislator it's very
different than elon Omar who used
exactly the same points that Tucker did
now there is a flip side to this because
I will grant the reason that we're
talking about this Media Matters thing
the reason that their attack worked is
because in politics or political media
your language is your instrument your
words are the instrument of politics
politics is just meaningful speech
Tucker knows this so when he goes on the
shock jock show he talks like a shock
jock you'd be like let's say that you're
a classically trained violinist and you
love to play Brahms you don't join a
rock band to play Brahms you don't show
up to the rock band rehearsal and start
playing the Brandenburg Concerto or
something or the mass and B minor
but you don't do that you play the rock
music or you don't join the rock band
this so this is why by the mean this is
why the fair criticism is Tucker
shouldn't have gone on this show I don't
think I would go on a show like that
probably not if I did maybe I'd try to
be a little less salty but I don't know
it's people you know people go through
different phases in their careers and in
their life in their personalities this
is why people have to be very careful
with words in this day and age as
because everything you say is recorded
forever but what really matters okay I'm
willing to grant that speech really
matters mmm bitter speech rather of
speech matters in politics but what
really matters at this moment in this
context listen to Chris Cuomo's take
this BS is currency for them they get
paid for this the base likes their
heroes to be base they've seen this
president make it to the White House in
part by doing the same thing now a lot
of this stuff that's coming up at least
about Carlson is from years ago when he
was desperate for attention here's the
test would he say the same things today
no no he's too busy playing the victim
he'd only say that he was naughty but he
wouldn't repeat them tonight why not
come on big man read the list of all the
things that you said and do it again and
show that you mean it come on you're not
more about the money now than you are
about the truth or are you he says
apologizing to the mob costs people
their jobs what a coward
why don't you repeat what you said if
it's not such a big deal you're not
going to apologize he's being treated
unfairly by those criticizing the same
give me a break see this guy and the
others for what they are if you mean it
own it don't just protect your money and
your fame or infamy in your case
apologize if you want but that takes
character that is strength that is
integrity
oh and that you did something wrong
character integrity own that you do
something wrong the mainstream media
along with Media Matters think that
Tucker is dangerous to their agenda and
what's the agenda well here's just one
example Chris Cuomo is brother Andrew
Cuomo
just legalize the killing of babies as
they're being born in the state of New
York and he took away the protections
where if their mother is killed that
would be counted as double murder now
that's not counted as double murder even
if she's nine months pregnant and then
he cheered it on and then he said god
bless you to all of the infanticidal
maniacs who were there clamoring to kill
babies as they're being born that's
Chris Cuomo his brother that's one okay
that's one thing to consider and Tucker
Carlson 13 years ago told offensive
jokes in a shock jock show what matters
here the reason they are connected the
reason this isn't the the left likes to
accuse us of what about ISM the reason
this isn't what about ISM is that the
left isn't actually upset about the
salty language the left uses plenty of
salty language for themselves what the
left is upset about is that Tucker
Carlson is having an impact on our
politics is influencing people to oppose
their agenda what is their agenda
killing babies as they're being born
whose agenda is it not just the left
broadly not just some wacko in Virginia
quiz Cuomo's brother quiz croak was
bababa
Fredo Cuomo now I sound like Chris Cuomo
Chris Cuomo his brother he talks about
integrity about character I'll take the
man who uses salty offensive language
any day over the one who kills a baby as
he's being born context really really
matters you which is more important by
the way Media Matters they'll do it to
every one of us they will do it to every
single one of us anyone that they deem a
threat they'll find something we said
you know at I don't know Howard Stern's
Bar Mitzvah in 1981 or something and
they'll and they will use it they will
use it to try to shut you up it has
nothing to do with what they said we are
not debating what Tucker Carlson said
what Tucker Carlson said is meaningless
it doesn't matter at all it is just an
excuse to fight an actual battle battle
over policies over which direction this
country is going to go so much more to
get to we got to talk about why it is
that it always seems like big people on
the Left move over to the right but big
people on the right don't move over the
left talked about that with regard to
Greenpeace and impeachment but ran out
of time I will be back in the studio
tomorrow so I guess we'll see you then
we'll have to talk about it tomorrow in
the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show the Michael
Knowles show is produced by Robert
Sterling executive producer Jeremy Moore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jessa all Vera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19